well we all know that Las Vegas is
becoming a major hub for sports this
weekend it's being billed as the biggest
women's Collegiate gymnet gymnastics
competition top Olympians from across
the country representing 16 different
universities and colleges will be here
and you can see them Joshua progero is
live this morning from The Orleans Arena
to tell us more Joshua you're getting
ready to learn a move or two I see
you've done a wardrobe change what are
you about to do
yeah so I'm gonna do a forward roll uh
hopefully but you know again this is the
super 16 and some of these uh Collegiate
athletes are going to be here are hoping
to represent the U.S in the 2024 Paris
Summer Olympics I'm joined by three-time
Olympian John Roethlisberger who I'm
gonna hand the mic twos and it tells me
a little bit uh what he wants me to do
all right Josh this is uh I'm scared
first of all I'm I'm worried about your
your skills but we we practice so what
you're going to do is you're going to
start just like this is Vegas you got to
sell it okay so you got to start we're
gonna go forward roll all right this is
his routine that was absolutely hideous
um that's fine though that was more of a
laurel cartwheel let's do your cartwheel
we've worked a lot on this
it's finished sell it sell it another
cartwheel another cartwheel Josh Focus
buddy
that I don't know what that was but you
got to sell it you're in Vegas you got
to sell it finish with finish with your
log roll AKA forward roll
beautiful beautiful get you gotta get
now you got to do the big finish the
head's got to go back though you Gotta
Throw the head back turn to the camera
you got to sell it you got to do a fist
pump
there's gonna be an Olympic floor
champion on this floor tonight and I
don't know if you just Dishonored her or
or that will be a tribute to her but
that was impressive hopefully at 6 45
when this happens again I'll have these
moves
broken down and again for the public or
I have to lose Master for the public
this this is an event they could attend
you can buy tickets at the um Orleans
arena.com reporting live at The Orleans
Arena as you can tell I'm out of breath
Joshua Pajero eight news now hopefully
he didn't trade any muscles yeah ice
pack ice pack ice pack